مشاهدينا مستمرون في هذه التغطيه
الاخباريه للانفجار الذي وقع في منطقه
تقسيم المقتضى بالمشاه وسط اسطنبول هذا
وقال الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ان
امراه ضالعه في الانفجار مشيرا الى ان
التحقيقات ما زالت جاريه وخلال مؤتمر صحفي
اكد اردوغان ان الهجوم نفذ بقنبله
وجرحى اتمنى شفاء العاجل لهم وتم نقل
الضحايا الى المشافي وسنكشف القائمين على
التفجير وسينالون عقابهم في اسرع وقت
الارهاب لن يصل لمبتغاه والعناصر التي
تحاول النيل من الوحده التركيه لن تحقق
طموحها وسينال المجرمون عقابهم
قبل ذلك اعلن حاكم اسطنبول سقوط سته قتلى
وثلاثه وخمسين جريحا جرى الانفجار ووجه
المدعي العام في اسطنبول بفتح تحقيق في
الانفجار كما شهدت منطقه تقسيم السياحيه
المزدحمه في اسطنبول انتشارا امنيا كثيفا
عقب الانفجار من جانبه افاد مراسل العربيه
بان الانفجار نجم عن قنبله وضعت داخل
الحقيقه
الى ذلك اعرب وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه عن
ادانه المملكه باشد العبارات التفجير
الارهابي الذي استهدف منطقه تقسيم وادى
الى وفاه وجرح عدد من المدنيين واكد
الخارجيه السعوديه في بيان ان المملكه تقف
مع تركيا ضد هذا العمل الجبان معربه عن
تعازيها لذوي الضحايا والتمنيات بالشفاء
العاجل للمصابين
اذا مشاهدينا مازلنا بهذه التغطيه
المباشره للانفجار الذي وقع بعد
ظهر اليوم في منطقه او في شارع الاستقلال
في ميدان تقسيم
ونتج عنه سته قتله حتى الساعه و 50 جريح
بحسب الارقام الرسميه التركيه طبعا هذه
المنطقه من المعروف عنها لانها المقصد
الاول للسياح وبانها منطقه مقتضه جدا
بالاتراك وبكل الجنسيات التي تتوافد الى
تركيا هي منطقه سياحيه بحث هي ليست المره
الاولى التي تتعرض فيها لهجوم ارهابي كان
هناك عدد كبير من الهجمات الارهابيه التي
هزت تركيا في عام 2016
بمناطق مختلفه منها هجوم كان في منطقه
تقسيم
بهذا الشارع الذي يعني همم يكون عاده
بالسكر طبعا الرئيس التركي اردوغان علق
هذا الانفجار وكان العنوان العريض لحديث
اردوغان بانه استهداف لاسقاط الدوله هذا
الانفجار ياتي في توقيت سياسي حذر بالنسبه
للرئيس التركي وبالنسبه لتركيا طبعا هو
على ابواب الانتخابات الرئاسيه وهو بظل كل
ما يعني تقوله استطلاعات الراي من تدني
همم شعبيه الرئيس التركي دخل تركيا بضل كل
الاوضاع الاقتصاديه التي تمر بها البلاد
وطبعا الاوضاع السياسيه الخارجيه معنا من
اسطنبول مهند حافظ اوكله الكاتب الصحافي
استاذ مهند سابدا من هذه النقطه التي كنت
اتحدث عنها وهو التوقيت السياسي الحذر
والدقيق بالنسبه للرئيس التركي نحن نتحدث
عن يعني همم نقطه حرجه بالتاريخ ومسار
السياسي الرئيس التركي ماذا يعني هذا
الاستهداف وهذه العمليه بهذا التوقيت
بالذات
طبعا ساعتها المشاهدين رساله هو نحن ندخل
الان في مرحله جديده ايه لا يبدو لان
مرحله مظلمه ولكنها غير محمود اطلع
العواقب
يبدو لي ان هناك من يريد ان يشتغل ااا هذا
الوضع الداخلي التركي من حيث الشحن
الانتخابات والتجهيز لها وكذلك يقوم
بالهروب الى الامام من خلال همم ضغط الذي
يجري عليه بعض الجهاد الاقليميه مضغوطه
بالفعل وتريد ان تهرب الى الامام وبالتالي
اقامت بالتوفيق مع عناصر الارهابيه هذه
قراءه وليست معلومات قراءه وتخميم ان همم
هناك دوله اقليميه تريد ان تعرض الى
الامام علي هنا بشكل اساسي ايران تريد ان
تشغل الاعلام الدولي والعربي عما يحدث لها
من الداخل الايراني والضغط الشعبي
وبالتالي تريد ان تعرف ان تشغل همم الراي
العالمي عنها كي تتساقتها وتعيد شيئا شيئا
ما قامت به ثقل همم من قمع ايه مواطنيها
همم بالاضافه
بعض الجهات واولئك الارهابيه يعني هنا حزب
العماره كردستاني وعناصره الذين يريدون ان
يضربوا العمق التركي
هذا العاجل الذي ورد الان افاد مرصد نت
بلوكس لمراقبه انقطاعات الانترنت بتقليد
منصات التواصل الاجتماعي في تركيا بعد
الانفجار الذي شهدته منطقه تقسيم وقال
المرصد عبر تويتر ان شبكات التواصل
الاجتماعيه التي جرى تقيدها شملت تويتر
وانستغرام ويوتيوب وفيسبوك وذلك عقب
الانفجار لماذا هذا الخوف بعد هذا
الانفجار ولماذا هذا التعتيم على مواقع
التواصل خصوصا ان هناك ايضا ابتعاض داخلي
همم بيبي الشارع التركي من حملات القمع
للراي للمعارضين لكل يعني الوسط التركي
بالاون الاخيره
ليش قلقا ولكن في النهايه هذه عمليه امنيه
ولا عمليات الامنيه لها حساباتها وبالتالي
من قام بهذا العمل الارهابي ومن خطط له
موجودين في المنطقه كان لزاما امنيا ان
يكون هناك ضبط
التصوير ولي الدخول وللخروج في تلك
المنطقه الى ان تتبين السلطات من قام بهذا
العمل الارهابيه
ببعض الموجودين من خلال المتابعه
الميدانيه او متابعه الكاميرات هذا امر
وعمل امني
معروف لدى همم دول العالم وهو لا يعد
تركيا على العكس تركيا وحكمتها تريد ان
تكون شفافه مع مواطنها وان تعطي وتدعي
اليهم بالنتائج في اسرع وقت ممكن لذلك
تقوم بمثل هذه الاحتياطات الامنيه لكي
تضيق همم
الخيارات والحصار على من يستخدم
التواصل الاجتماعي للوصول الى نتائج
المرجوع
كنت تحدث عن طرف من التنظيمات الارهابيه
التي الذي يمكن ان يكون ضالعا بهذه
العمليه نحن امام سيناريوهات عند اليوم
واحد من هذه السيناريوهات هو ضلوع تنظيم
داعش فيها خصوصا ان هناك تاريخ طويل
لتنظيم مع القياده التركيه
وانها يعني
قمعت ولبن اوقفت عدد كبير من قيادته وهو
قام بعمليات عديده داخل تركيا هل ما زال
التنظيم ينشط الى هذا الحد وهذه القوه
لاختراق الامن التركي الان
لان العمليات الامنيه الاستخباراتيه ضد
عناصر داعش مستمره بشكل يومي على بشكل خاص
في مدينه اسطنبول باضافه الى المدن
التركيه كلها ولكن هناك حملات
واستخباراتيه وعملياتها وهي ضد اليك
العناصر الارهابيه سواء كانوا من داعش او
حتى على الحدود مع العراق وسوريا من عناصر
البيكيكي عناصر تنظيم حزب العمال
الكردستاني الارهابي في المحصله تركيا
المستهدفه من كثير من الارهابيين وكثير من
ده علمي اول ارهابيين وهم على شكل دول
يريدون الى
مطلبهم من كثر تركيا وان لا تقوم لتركيا
قائمه سيما انها مقبله على انتخابات
مفصليه مصريه
بها في طبيعه الحال ابقى معي يا استاذ
ايضا سينضم الينا استاذ العلاقات الدوليه
الدكتور سمير صالح استاذ سمير الغمز من
قناه فتح الله جولدن والذي لديه تاريخ
طويل من الصراع مع حزب العداله والتنميه
وتحديدا اردوغان والذي بدا تحديدا بالعام
2013 همم هل يعني الغمز من هذه القناه
بهذا التوقيت السياسي بالذات داخليا
وخارجيا لتركيا ماذا يعني
صحيح يعني طبعا كل شيء وارد
يبدو اننا فقدنا الدكتور سمير صالحه استاذ
مهند في اطرح سؤالنا
الان الان يمكننا سماعك
كما قلت لك قبل قليل السيناريوهات موجوده
الان علينا ان ننتظر نتائج التحقيقات التي
اجرائها اييي خمسه محققين
عقليين وفي عندنا العشرات او ربما المئات
من همم كاميرات المراقبه في شارع
الاستقلال مكان حدوث هذا العمل الارهابي
وكلها يساعد في تسريع عمليه تحقيقات
والكشف عن
الفاعلين لكن بالنسبه للثانيات نعم
اصابع همم مجموعات حزب العمال الارهابي
موجوده رايي انا الشخصيه الاقرب الاول ان
تكون هذه المجموعه ارهابيه وراء هذا
الاعمال لماذا لان في عمليات عسكريه تركيه
تنفذ بشكل ضد عناصر هذه المجموعه سوريا
العراق وفي الداخل تركي ارسنال والثاني
عناصر مجموعات داعش ايضا احتمال همم بعد
تضييق الخناق على داعش في شمال سوريا
والتصعيد التركي بهجه منع هذه المجموعات
التبدد او الانشاء كما حاولت ان تفعل قبل
اسابيع اكثر من سيناريو مجموعات
لكن كما قلت نطرح الاول بيريحنا من خلال
خصوصا انه كمل الاشاره الى وجود امراه
شاركت في هذه العمليه كما قيل هذه برايه
يقرب سيناري وان تكون مجموعات حزب العمال
هذا العمل لماذا لانه هي تستخدم اكثر
العنصر النساء في عمليات ارهابيه من هذا
الموقع
العنصر النساء في كثير من العمليات وخصوصا
عندما نتحدث عن عمليات الذئاب المنفرده
التي يعني نشرتها باخر ايامها باوروباعدد
من المناطق همم استاذ سمير يعني عندما
تتحدث عن حزب ال- عمال الكردستاني وبعد
العمليات التركيه التي شنها اردوغان ما
يعرف بعمليه قفل المخلب التركي بشمال
سوريا شمال وشرقي سوريا وايضا بالعراق كل
هذه العمليات بالاونه الاخيره الرد عليها
يكون داخل تركيا وكيف يثمر بالسياسه وهو
لن يرضع اردوغان عن عمليه العسكريه وخصوصا
انه مصره على القيام بها وعلى تطهير
الحدود قبل الانتخابات الرئاسيه
تماما اتفق معك يعني تشرين الى نقطه في
غايه الاهميه ستكون مرتبطه بنتائج
التحقيقات يعني اذا ما ثبت فعلا انه
مجموعات حزب العمال هي التي نفذت هذا
العمل الارهابي راي الشخصي من خلال
المتابعه سيكون هناك رد تركي واسعه ضد هذه
المجموعات الى جانب العمليات العسكريه
المنفذه سيكون هناك تسريع للعمليه التي
تحدثنا عنها اكثر من مره ولم تنفذها تركيا
حتى الان في شباب سوريا شباب سوريا
استاذ مهند اسمح لي ان انتقل استاذ سمير
الى استاذ مهند استاذ مهند كان هناك اسرار
تركي بالاونه الاخيره على القيام بهذه
العمليه جوبها برفض امريكي وايضا لم يكن
هناك مبارك روسيه لهذه العمليه في سوريا
وبالتالي جمدت نوعا ما هل يمكن ان تكون
هذه العمليه هي الذريعه
ممكن ان تحرك القوافل التركيه نحو شمال
سوريا من جديد
استاذ مهند هل تسمعني
على ما يبدو اننا فقدنا الاتصال الاستاذ
مهند استاذ سمير همم هل سمعت السؤال ام ام
يجب الاعاده
الى اصابع حزب العمال وراء هذا العمل
الارهابي فانا هو عندي سنناقش في فتره
زمنيه قصيره قريبه جدا همم مساله هذه
العمليه العسكريه التي تريدها تركيا التي
لم تنفذها حتى الان لماذا يعني همم
بالنسبه للتركيا لانه لابد من ان يكون
هناك حقيقي على هذه المجموعات التي قامتها
لانها جزء من حزب العمال
وتساعده في شمال سوريا
ايضا الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان كما يعني
ايضا قليل لم يلغي برنامج زيارته الى قمه
ال 20 المجموعه 20 هذا يعني انه همم انقر
لا تريد موقع ان تفتح طريق امام المجموعات
الارهابيه للوصول الى ما تريده سواء كان
من الناحيه السياسيه النفسيه او غير ذلك
صحيح انه هذا العمل تم في بقعه جغرافيه
مهمه جدا منطقه سياحيه اساسيه في قلب
اسطنبول لكن الاصرار الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان على السفاري الى بالي والمشاركه
في قمه مجموعه العشرين هذا يعني بحجزته
همم اصرار تركي على عدم فتح الطريقه امام
هذه المجموعات ايرانيه تاخذ ما تريدون
لذلك عندي قبل قليل عندما طرحتي سؤال ايضا
مهم انه هذه المجموعات من خلال الاعمال
اراديه من هذا النوع يعني كيف ستكون رجل
فعلا تركيا
كانت انه قرار الرئيس التركي عدم الغاء
برنامج زياده رايته الى الخارج همم عاده
ما يعني العمليات الامنيه التي تحصل يتم
استثمار بالسياسه همم وايضا شد العصبيات
كيف سيستخدم الرئيس التركي او كيف ممكن ان
تخدم الرئيس التركي بهذه المرحله
نتائج التحقيق دائما ان يتوقف الان عند
هذه النقطه نتائج التحقيق
تحديد الجهه الفائده
في الايام القليله المقبله على نقاش اكثر
من ماده مرتبطه سواء كان بهذا العمل او في
الاجواء السياسيه في الداخل التركي لكن
انا رئيس شخصيه
لا الحكم ولا المعارضه يذهب في هذه
المرحله هذه الفتره الزمنيه القصيره وراء
محاوله استفاده او استغلال هذه الحادثه
اظن انه ردود الفعل كلها في تركيا ستلتقي
عند نقطه اساسيه لذينه الحادثه والكشف عن
الفاعلين والتعامل معينه باسرع ما يكون
اما الشق المرتبط بمحاوله لاعب الورقه
لحسبيه انت غبيه او غير ذلك داخل عنا فتره
زمنيه براي انا ايضا طويله جدا ثمانيه
الذهاب الى الصناديق لابد ان يكون هناك
اكثر من حدث ايضا هذه النقاشه
ولكن يعني عندما نتحدث عن الامن الداخلي
هو نقطه حمراء بالنسبه للشعب التركي همم
استاذ ابقى مع استاذ سمير واستاذ مهند
سينضم الينا الزميل زيدان زي كل مراسل
العربيه من اسطنبول للاطلاع على اخر
التطورات من هناك وهل من جديد زيدان
بالتحقيقات او
بالتصريحات الرسميه
او رسميا نتحدث عن تصريح الرئيس التركي
الذي اعلن ارتفاع عدد القتلى الى سته
اشخاص او ست الفتله و53 جريح طبعا الرئيس
تحدث عن ان امراه اعتقد خلف هذا
الهجوم همم لكن ما نتحدث هو الان عن مصادر
غير رسميه همم بعض وسائل الاعلام نشرت
مقاطع فيديو لكاميرات مراقبه قائدنا الامن
التركي يحقق في هذه المقاطع المقاطع
همم من همم من تحت احد المقاعد في وسط
شارع الاستقلال طبعا همم التكهنات همم
ترجح ان قنبله كانت موضوعه في حقيبه همم
وضعتها امراه تحتها هذا المقعد ومن ثم مضت
وبعدها ان غادرت جرى او حدث الانفجار هذه
هي الان النظريه الاكثر ترجيحا من قبل همم
الامن التركي كما تؤكد بعض المصادر
التركيه لكن كما ذكرت لا يوجد رسمي من قبل
الحكومه التركيه حول كيفيه حدوث الانفجار
او من هي الامراه التي تحدث عنها الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان لكن الان يمكن ان
نتحدث عن تصريح باسم همم المتحدث باسم
الرئاسه التركيه ابراهيم همم قبل حوالي
اللحظات يتحدث همم اولا يترحم ابراهيم كان
وهو متحدثا على ارواح قتلى شفاء
سعوديين ويتحدث عن السلطات التركيه تقوم
بفحص الحادث بطرق عديده وستثم ويستم الكشف
عن همم تفاصيل الحادث بكل ابعاده وهذا
الحادث لن يكون قادرا على كسر عزم تركيه
او عزم تركيا ومقاومتها هذا هو تصريح
المتحدث باسم الرئاسه التركيه همم
ابراهيم كالين همم ربما الان هذا هو احدث
التصريحات همم الرسميه
56 جريح
نعم ستبقى 53 من ذبيح هو اخر حصيله ااا
تم الحديث عنها لكن كما ذكرت
الانظار تتجه حول معركه هويه الامراه التي
فجرت نفسها او عفوا التي تقف خلف الهجوم
ااه نستبعد تماما او باسم المستبعد تماما
الان النظريه النجوم انتحاري النظريه
الاكثر ترجيحا الانديه ان الانفجار وقع
نتيجه قنبله همم وضعت تحت احد المقاله هذه
المعلومات تفسيرها مجددا همم يتم الحمل
الحديث ايضا
عن ان
التحقيقات او الكاميرات
بموضوع التحقيقات او اي تطور بموضوع
الاحصائيات الرسميه للقتلى والجرحى بهذه
المنطقه بعد الانفجار الذي هز شارع
الاستقلال وتحديدا في ميدان التقسيم في
تركيا نعم نعم
الصوت الان
شكرا لك سنعود اليك فورا ورود اي جديد
بموضوع التحقيقات او بالارقام الرسميه
المعلنه اعد اليك استاذ مهند حافظ اوغلو
استاذ مهند يعني ايضا كل ما يحصل او ما
حصل اليوم بهذا التفجير ياتي بوقت يتصاعد
فيه الاعداء بين احزاب المعارضه وحسب
العداله والتنميه كيف يمكن استثمار هذا
الحادث بالسياسه
طبعا من الممكن ان تستثمره المعارضه فعينه
بالخلل الامني الذي
الحكومه وبالتالي بدايه
اعلاميه لاجل الانتخابات انا لا استبعد ان
تكون هناك محاولات من قبل المعارضه بالرغم
من انهم يتفقون على ان الارهاب يجب
محاربته وضربه وايقافه ولكن ااه بما ان
المعارضه التركيه قد سحبت من يدها همم
اغلب او كل الاوراق التي تواجه بها
الحكومه التركيه في الانتخابات القادمه
كانت لديها ورقه همم الاقتصاد وورقه
اللاجئين همم في تركيا وبعد ان سحبت منها
هذه الورقات من خلال همم اعاده ترتيب
الاوراق السياسه الخارجيه التركيه همم
ومحاوله الحكومه التركيه
الاقتصاد يبدو انها قد جاءت همم العمل
الارهابي على طبق من ذهب لكي تستثمره ضد
الحكومه التركيه ضد الرئيس
تفضل على انهم منقسمون فيما بينهم يريدون
امام ان يكون بين ايديهم ليحاج به الحكومه
التركيه ويبدو لانهم ربما سوف يستغلوا هذا
الامر همم استاذ سمير اليوم ايضا هذا
التفجير ياتي بتوقيت عاده فيه الرئيس
اردوغان للاعب دور سياسي اتحدث هنا عن
الموضوع الروسي الاوكراني عن ملف ايران
ايضا في المنطقه وبالتالي عن لحظه سياسيه
مختلفه عن الاشهر الماضيه ماذا يعني ذلك
وكيف يمكن ان ينعكس فرمله ببعض الملفات
وتسريع للملفات الاخرى
شيرين يعني نقطه في رايه الاهميه لماذا
قبل قليل تحدثنا عن اكثر من سيناريو في
حول الجهه التي من المحتمل ان تكون هي
التي تقف وراء هذا العمل الارهابي تحدثنا
عن موضوع حزب العمال موضوع داعش تنظيم
داعش عن موضوع الكائن الموازي مجموعه
مرتبطه بتنظيم فتح الله بلال اظن الان
سيناريو التي سينقل الذي سينقش ايضا هو
اصابع ايران في عمل ارهابي من هذا النوع
صحيح كما شر قليل العلاقات التركيه
الايرانيه المتوتره في اكثر من ملف في
نقاط تباعد كثيره صحيح ايضا انه ايران
اكثر من مره في بعض المدن التركيه من خلال
محاوله الاستهداف مواطنين اسرائيليين تحت
في عمليات توقيف اعتقالات ضد بعض الخلايا
الايرانيات لذلك المرتبط بوجود اصابع
ايرانيه
تاجيج الخلاف العراق التركي في الماضيه
ايضا
نقطه مهمه جدا
بعين الاعتبار الى جانب هذا التباعد
التركي الايراني في التعامل مع ملفات بطبع
اقليمي استراتيجي تحديدا في موضوع ضروري
يقاس موضوع كهربا كما تعرفين موضوع القطه
كل هذه النقاط الان الملف السوري ايضا
منزعجه من هذا الحوار او هذا التقارب
التركي الروسي في التعامل مع الملف لكن هل
تغامر ايران دخول ورائها قيام بعمل ارهابي
من هذا النوع عارف انه ارتدادات هذه تكون
قاسيه ليس فقط على العلاقات التركيه
الايرانيه بل علاء مصالح ايران مع العديد
من دول المنطقه هذه
تدفعنا للقولون انه ايران تفكر بشكل دقيق
جدا قبل المحاوله
القيام بعمل من هذا انه نعم همم اسمحوا لي
مشاهدينا عن اشكر همم كل من الاستاذ سمير
صالح استاذ العلا
الدوليه الدكتور سمير صالحه وايضا من
اسطنبول مهند حافظ اوغلو الكاتب الصحفي
وساعيد التذكير باننا كنا نتابع معكم هذه
التغطيه للانفجار الذي حصل في اسطنبول
وتحديدا في ميدان تقسيم في جده الاستقلال
والذي نتج عنه سته قتله و53 جريحا حتى
الساعه بحسب الارقام الرسميه التركيه اول
تصريح للرئيس التركي اردوغان اعتبر فيه
بانه استهداف للدوله وايضا يعني لم يقطع
زيارته وكل الزياره الرسميه او المشاركه
الرسميه لتركيا في قمه ال 20 همم مشاهدينا
لمتابعه المزيد عن هذا الموضوع ابقى معنا
ومع العربيه عبر مواقع العربيه وعبر النقل
المباشر للعربيه